وتنضم الينا من طرابلس
مرحبا تسمعيني رينا
لا ما بسمع صباح الخير كيف صحتك تمام
صباح النور صباح النور طيب بدايه خلينا
نسالك عن قصه صحن الفتوش اللي تحول الى
ازمه مؤخرا
نعم لا شك انه الازمه الاقتصاديه الخانقه
التي يعيشها لبنان منذ سنوات ارخت بضلالها
على كهل المواطن اللبناني ودفعت الكثير من
الناس الى اعاده النظر بخياراتهم وبنمط
حياتهم يعني فنحن الان على ابواب الشهر
الفضيل يعني هناك ماكولات كثيره قد يعني
يتم استبدالها على المائده الرمضانيه نظرا
لكلفتها او يتم استبدالها باطباق اخرى اقل
كلفه فمثلا صحن الفتوش هذا الطبق اليومي
الذي يزين المائده الرمضانيه والفتوش يعني
هي سلطه مشهوره في بلاد الشام بلغ يعني
صحن كلفه الصحن الواحد 245 الف ليره بحسب
الدوليه للمعلومات في احصاء جديد 245 الف
للشخص الواحد يعني طبق الفتوش للعائله من
اربعه اشخاص يلامسوا المليون ليره اليوم
ليث في وقت لا يزال الكثير من اللبنانيون
يعتقدون رواتبهم على سعر صرف 1500 ليره
وبالليره اللبنانيه اشير الى انه طبق
الفتوش قبل الازمه يعني ب 2019 لم يكن
يتخطى ال 4,000 ليره فقط
يعني تخيلوا انه طبق مثل الفتوش قد يكون
خارج قدره الكثير من اللبنانيين في هذه
الفتره وقد يتم استبداله بسلطات اخرى اقل
كلفه مثل سلطه الملفوف اوصلت البقله مع
البندوره او الركبه مع البصل علما انه حتى
البصل يكسب له الف حساب نعم هذا عند
الافطار ولكن ماذا عن حصه لبنان في كعكه
المسلسلات الرمضانيه اذا صح التعبير
نعم يعني رمضان هو يعني مائده الافطار
الجميله والمسلسلات الرمضانيه الكثيره اذا
كنت من متابعي هذه المسلسلات فاتتكون على
موعد مع باقه كبيره من المسلسلات العربيه
المشتركه لان هنا اشير ان الانتاج
اللبناني الدرامي تراجع مع الازمه ولاسباب
نعرفها ايضا مرتبطه بكلفه الانتاج
والمنتجين ولكن
الانتاجات العربيه المشتركه لقد نجاحا
كبيرا فنحن على موعد مع مسلسل للموت الذي
تم تصوير الجزء الثالث منه بعد نجاحين في
الجزئين الماضيين طبعا المسلسل هو من
بطوله اللبنانيتين ماجي بوغصن ودانيلا
رحمه وبقى من الممثلين السوريين نذكرهم
محمد الاحمد تفاصيل هذا المسلسل وقصته رهن
المتابعه في الايام القليله المقبله وايضا
لابد من الاشاره الى المسلسل النار من
النار الى النار وهي يعني مقتبس عن قصه
واقعيه لويليام شكسبير وتروي قصه حاره
يسكنها الناس من جنسيات مختلفه والعلاقه
الاجتماعيه والعاطفيه المعقده بينهم ويمكن
يعني اذا اردنا تطبيقه فقد يكون انعكاس
للازمه
للوجود السوري في لبنان
المسلسل من بطوله عابد فهد وكنيس بشار
وشوش خباز وغيرهم شكرا شكرا
العربيه من طرابلس اللبنانيه وليست طرابلس
الليبيه